les photos des chroniqueurs donc je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure si vous venez de
nous rejoindre il y a un scientifique
qui basait un petit peu sur les
architectes à créer une sorte
d'algorithme qui crée l'homme et la
femme parfaite voilà les yeux parfaits
le visage parfait les lèvres parfaites
si tout est à 100 % ça donne l'homme le
plus beau du monde ou la femme la plus
belle du monde et peut-être qu'un jour
on pourra même les construire
scientifiquement on en est pas encore
quand je vois votre tête là on en est
pas encore donc on a essayé avec les
chroniqueurs on a pris le meilleur de
chacun alors pour l'homme
voilà mais ça selon l'ordi on a pris le
meilleur de chacun de vous donc il y a
peut-être la chemise alors je vais vous
dire qu'il y a
le meilleur de toi c'est ta chemise
c'est ce qu'on voit pas super alors je
vais vous dire là-dessus il y a les yeux
de qui à votre avis de Laurent bravo ah
ouais la mâchoire
alors c'est pas de balle parce que le
seul truc qu'on a pris de Benoît c'est
de la chirurgie esthétique mais c'est la
mâchoire ah d'accord mâchoire de Benoît
le sourire c'est qui Florian
de splato les sourcils
j'espère que c'est pas les miens
oui parce que tu as des sourcils très
très féminins très très fort
les cheveux c'est les tiens bravo
absolument
l'ordi c'est le mec le plus beau du
monde de TPMP
et vous avez pas vu la femme alors
maintenant regardez la femme et la femme
[Musique]
la femme alors comme j'ai pu ma fille
c'est quoi ma c'est la mes cheveux
le reste qu'on a la bouche c'est Sophie
de Sophie
généreuse gourmande voilà et qu'est-ce
qu'on a d'autre et qu'est-ce qu'on a les
sourcils et la mâchoire c'est qui
c'est les plus moches du plateau
c'est les dents de qui
c'est les dents de qui je demande
direct
mais toi tu as rien à changer tu es
magnifique de haut en bas paraît-il